congratulations on your results how
confident are you that they could be
replicated at a general election
well we have had a fantastic set of
election results as you say across
england scotland and wales
and we've seen a real revival in rural
areas such as somerset and cumbria and
we've made real inroads into new areas
in what we call our blue wall area uh
places like west oxfordshire and
wimbledon and eastern walton and
harpenden places where liberal democrats
are currently in second place and where
we want to target conservative mps at
the next general election of course we
never ever take votes for granted um and
so we will
we will be working very hard uh over the
coming months and years to ensure that
we can win the support and votes of
people in these areas
um well you've of course got the tibetan
and hollington by-election coming up
that one triggered by uh the resignation
of neil paris for watching pornography
dominic robb admitted he actually faces
a tough fight in his seat as well at the
next general election in those two
places specifically are you confident
that we could still live mmps
well certainly in eastern walton which
is dominic raab seat we have a very
strong local government base now and
we're hopeful that that is a seat that
we might be able to win at the next
general election um and in tibetan and
honeton i think you can see that really
across the whole of the south west
actually new liberal democrats have a
very strong history of being the key
challenges to the conservatives in that
area and we are starting to see a
revival there and if there's one message
we can take from these local elections
it's that people are really fed up of
being taken for granted in both of these
places and many more places as well
whether it's the party gate scandals
whether it's misleading parliament
whether it's the cost of living crisis
or running our health services into the
ground people are really sick and tired
of being taken for granted
now of course it's important to you know
qualify some of what we've been saying
by the fact that these are local
elections people do vote very
differently in a general election tends
to be for
bigger parties um but what the results
do point towards you know according to
the sky news analysis as well is a hung
parliament with neither labor or the
conservatives managing to get a majority
would the lib dems be prepared to go
into a coalition
well the outcome of the next general
election is entirely in the hands of the
voters we don't even know when the next
general election is going to be we don't
know what the mood or the state of the
country is going to be and but the
message that we've got from this these
local elections is that people are
really really scared about the cost of
living emergency that is happening
just to come in again on the possibility
of a coalition you won't rule out doing
a coalition either with the
conservatives or with labour then
um our number one priority for the
liberal democrats is ousting this
conservative government we have no
interest in doing a coalition with this
conservative government at all and we
have said that we are second place to
the conservatives in around 80 seats
around the country and those are the
areas where we will be targeting
conservative mps and we want to play a
role in ousting them but right now
look the outcome of the next general
election is in the hands of the voters
right now what voters have been telling
us over the last few days in the run-up
to the local elections is that there is
a cost of living emergency which is why
we want to see an emergency vat cut in
the queen's speech they are fed up with
their health services being driven into
the ground people can't see their gp
just to be crystal clear then you won't
rule out a coalition with the labour
party
liberal democrats have said that we want
to win as many seats as possible off the
conservatives at the next general
election and one way or another we would
like to play a role in ousting this
conservative government it's far too
soon to say what that might look like or
how that might work but we would want to
play a role in ousting this conservative
government that's our number one
priority okay i think reading between
the lines that's actually quite clear
and
just finally i want to ask you a
question about kierstama um
if he is found and to have broken
covered laws by durham police if he's
issued with a fixed penalty notice does
he need to resign
well i think it's absolutely vital for
public trust that these allegations are
investigated
i'm sure they will be investigated
thoroughly and i hope they'll be
investigated quickly as well but what i
think is really important to remember is
that there was only one man who wrote
these rules these rules that separated
families at these key moments of of
children's births and people's deaths
and really it was boris johnson who
wrote those rules he was on tv screens
every single night telling us we had to
follow them or people's lives would be
lost and it's he it's boris johnson who
wrote the rules broke the rules and is
now subject to three different
investigations